hey guys it's Johanna here so how many
of you have a Swiss ball that is
collecting that summer at home or
perhaps you are not too sure exactly how
to use it then this workout is for you
I'll be guiding you through a food 20
minute beginners through spa workout
that will strengthen all the major
muscle groups and turn the body without
any additional equipment all you need is
a Swiss ball and your energy right guys
so let's first start by understanding
how to choose the right useful size for
your height so he comes in three
different sizes small medium and large
what I have here is a small Swiss ball
so when you are set on the Swiss ball
your feet should be flat on the floor
and your legs should in 90 degrees so if
you are shorter than 5 to 4 go for a
small Swiss ball if you are between 5 4
2 5 7 then go for medium Swiss ball and
if you are tall about 5 7 9 go for a
large Swiss ball there are the total of
nine exercises 45 seconds per workout
with 15 seconds of rest so the first one
girl is going to be overhead ball squat
start in a narrow stance squat down and
as you come up
bring the ball above your head with your
upper body okay step 1 bring it down and
bring it back up so I'm going to set my
timer remember to breathe to get your
own pace and the more you do it the
better you will get so ready
never squat down and push it up good
push your butt out squat and bring it up
so this is a nice gentle warm-up where
you will be working on your lower body
and your upper body as well so really
freeze your pop out and bring it up good
squat up very nice up freeze output
within every valve good narrow squat
bring it up step 1 push your bum out up
good several seconds bring it down up
down and stretch your body out narrow
let's go one more and rest the second
workout is wall squat so just place the
ball on the ball against the wall the
ball should rest my sleeve of your waist
and take a step forward as you squat
down your legs should be 90 degrees I
want you to go as low and bring it up
good so try to tighten your core squat
for your bum and push up with your fuse
good job nice and control push it up so
you should really feel your thighs
working and when you come up squeeze
your bum very very good ahh nice down
control squeeze it up so try not to lean
your weight too much back instead try to
hold your car in and really control and
you feel legs thighs butt muscles
ten more seconds I'm going to go down
and just hold it just hold it here so
mean let's go for five more seconds
again open five more seconds and just
release it well done next we shop we
want to get into our upper body push-ups
so just bring the ball onto your belly
take a step forward get to where you're
comfortable without arching your back
and just get into a small push-up good
alright so let's do this for 45 seconds
the better you get and if you wants to
reach yourself more then bring the Swiss
ball even further back all right
the further back you bring it the more
challenging it will be good keep going
down that up very nice I've got such a
tight space I hope you can see me ten
more seconds tighten your core because
the last thing you want is to arch your
back good we're going to
body good and just roll it back and
relax nuts back into the same position I
want you to do to work on your back
right now there the game Bowl on your
belly go forward all right put your
place your feet against the wall and
just extend your back up all right so as
you bring you back up squeeze and feel
your lower back working good a squeeze
as high as you can no and squeeze very
nice
so now we are working on our lower back
if you want to work on your mid-back you
can add this slight move and squeeze it
good
so extend forward squeeze good stretch
squeeze ten more seconds reach squeeze
reach squeeze reach squeeze and relax
now down onto the mat all right place
your feet on the ball move your bum up a
bit straight and I'm going to bring it
in extend straight and creole mix in so
try to keep your body in a straight line
throughout the workout and you should
really feel your hamstrings working
really engage your core in order to keep
the ball balanced and to keep your body
in a straight line as well so nice and
control roll it in and work in the
hamstrings and your path to bring it a
good extent in expand in few more extend
curling can you feel your hamstrings
good in and real
now I want you to go back onto your
belly we want to work more on our butt
which is leg raises okay to get onto
your belly
roll slightly forward and just bring
your leg up and squeeze the butt okay so
let's alternate the legs squeeze the
back squeeze it as high as you can
squeeze it again the further you reach
forward the more challenging it will be
for you so balance itself squeezing
balance and squeeze good
so this will really turn your path the
more you squeeze the more muscles you
will be engaging good squeeze squeeze
nice squeeze whoo ten more seconds
get those butt muscles working come on
ladies squeeze squeeze squeeze and rest
in the same position we want to get into
Jack nine and work on our ABS so go
forward I guess the further back you
bring the Swiss ball the more
challenging you will be so start about
knee level bring the ball in and squeeze
your lower abs okay extend it bring the
ball games we go ABS
extend it and bring your butt up all
right so you should feel your abs
working your legs and also you have the
body which is supporting you
good keep going bring your butt up
squeeze good extend squeeze to make this
more challenging bring the streets ball
further towards your ankle extend
squeeze ten more seconds
remember not to arch your back so always
try to the coal and keep a straight back
last few more
and rest okay whoops just rolled it back
and down we want to get into all the
traditional plank on a Swiss ball so
beginners again you can start on your
knees are get onto your toe toes okay
this is more challenging only because it
requires more stability when you need
more stability it will work more on your
core muscles so just hold it there and
just hold it for 45 seconds that's it so
breathe relax control if you want to
challenge yourself even more then you
can move the Swiss ball slightly back
and forth which would really target and
kill your core good just fall back and
fall smooth with ten more seconds come
on let's move it back and forth slightly
whether you're on your knees or on your
toes you just keep going and rest and
the final five workout is hand off this
is really do to work with the entire
core so stop with the sweet spot in your
hand as you crunch up pause the Swiss
ball to your leg bring it down extend
your arms crunch up and bring it back up
okay this is not an easy workout it is
challenging so remember to take your own
pace and do as many reps as you can get
stretch bring it in pass the ball over
back good
so can you feel your abs and your upper
abs working as you are passing the ball
through keep going stay strong ten more
seconds remember to hold the Swiss ball
firmly between your legs well
and rest stretch it up pretty well I
just take a short breather okay and now
yes I'm not ready because you have a
full 1 minute rest and we will repeat
the entire workout again so grab another
drink relax breathe and for the second
round me more energy able cover foam
always remember to tighten your core and
focus on your core this lot about
rushing the workout instead is it is
about getting the right techniques in
order to get and target the right
muscles so kept aside some dreams okay
15 more seconds
five more seconds grab your swiss ball
and let's start with narrow squad all
right squat down bring it up good
why ah very good
so let's aim to work on your lower body
and your upper body too
let's go bring the speed up slightly
let's do in to focus on proper form down
oh good
up down and up very nice
let's keep moving whoo
breathe in bring it down without when
you're half down up in out get let's get
going
ten more seconds you're almost there
hoop down and up very very good and up
now face the ball on the wall we are
going straight into wall squats and
that's how it with the end of the ten
seconds so remember to bring your feet
forward because you wanted to be nice to
degrees ready let's go down up you can
place your hands in front of you
remember to go low and squeeze it up low
control squeeze push me that hill
squeeze your bum good down squeeze toes
pointed forward squeeze very very nice
squeeze again whatever workers you do
engage your core muscles okay you're
going up it's so warm right down in this
room right let's go down and hold the
spot or ten seconds of me
so who breathe out I know your face
muscles are hurting your bum and just
relax good let's get straight into push
on so again to make it easier bring the
streets walk closer to your belly so
make it harder further towards
go ready let's go and let's go down one
good two three as many as you can
without sacrificing propofol so it's not
just about going up and down
it's about tightening your core and
keeping your body in a nice straight
line
remember this is wrong I don't want to
see your arching back tighten your core
keep going good alright are you doing
you only get stronger ten more seconds
down it up the best thing is to rest it
on your knees to begin with
keep going a few more and rest so just
bring it back they still fit against the
wall we are going straight into back
extension all right nicely together
belly and get ready
stretch out boots bring it back squeeze
your work and your upper and knee back
squeeze good all the way down squeeze
you can do it Tyson or if you want and
squeeze good touch squeeze
remember to really squeeze your muscles
in order to work and engage that if
you're not feeling tired if you're not
feeling your muscles then slow the
movement down and check your form again
let's go oh I think you might also be
feeling on your butt muscles as it's
squeezing up good ah
extend up do you more good enough back
on to the net because we want to work on
our hamstrings leg curls lie down be on
the ball ready
yes bring your body up straight curl it
in place your hand nicely on the poor
and he's all about engaging your core to
keep it really straight and who you like
in to work it in hamstrings good pull it
in
same thing do not drop a belly or your
lower back curl whoa good job my
hamstrings are so sore from I'm working
on yesterday keep going curl it in
extend curl extend curl ten more seconds
curl curl extend her oh well done
now then come to our belly leg extension
next muscle is the bump alright nice
unit Ally have it nice and secure
let's go squeeze squeeze good squeeze
nice good keep going good very good
really squeeze the trick of your bombs
nice keep going
let's not stop now you are almost there
only five whole minutes and you will be
done squeeze squeeze and I'll just give
this ten small pulses three four five
six stay high seven eight nine ten
change
one two stay high three four five six
seven eight in going nine ten good and
now rest
sj9 okay so start around new knees come
forward ready let's go removals in sweet
little ass extend
bring your butt up and squeeze it good
I want to see just sweat dripping on the
floor or in your mat good in lift your
bum and you core up in nice squeeze
extend high core and I see a sweat
dripping good stay strong in extend in
eventually this would be extremely easy
for you keep going in whoa last few more
one more and just gently roll it back
and now let's get string into play oh my
god
I am dripping ready let's go and it's
not all good right let's hold it
I follow miss the cue there so just
really tighten your core to make it more
challenging you can bring your feet
together as well okay
I just place your arms open with your
palms facing up I just relax breathe and
you want just meditate without good
right are you ready let's go back and
forth very very slightly keep going
strong core ten more seconds
strong core come on this is your second
loss workouts you can do it cause your
head and just relax final workout hand
off okay get some space
oh my god I am so sweaty right you [ __ ]
you
right close it over nice and firm pass
it over and extend good extend I so need
to get the biggest space poop squeeze up
apps only bring your legs as low without
arching your back nice come on it is
aching
I am aching I am absolutely hurts me but
we do not stop when we're tight we stop
when we're done keep going five more
seconds left without in extend and good
good job I'm not even gonna help I'm
just gonna lie here place the ball under
my legs and just relax and stretch it
out quickly all right I am absolutely
drenched in sweat
I even have sweat on my stress ball if
you are feeling strong then repeat
all the exercises once more in to do
this workout three times weekly on
alternate days for best result combine
this workout together with another three
sessions of cardio working out with
Swiss ball is a great way to strengthen
the body and core to increase stability
and of course to tone and slim the body
Plus this is low-impact so it is safe
and effective for almost everybody so do
this and share your results all the best
for new Fitness food and motivational
videos please like share and subscribe
to my youtube channel and website do
follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter to stay connected with me thanks
guys
you